she's up talking about the crew of
Kingsman the Golden Circle by now we've
all heard about the prank war between
Channing Tatum and Halle Berry
it is fantastic but as Carly Steele
found out the pranks on set didn't
really discriminate well I put a
mannequin in his bed in his trailer all
he did was put a wig on my pillow the
wrong trailer like I was a cub but then
on the day he left he filled my trailer
with sex dolls we spent 1,500 bucks I
hope you Fitness is soon to go and get
them otherwise you're like isn't
bothering about insect shops so I would
love to so the prank war is over now is
the prank war ever done the answer would
be no if you ask fellow prankster Halle
Berry she's new to the Kingsmen
franchise and so is Julianne Moore she's
the villain and was convinced to join
the cast by her good friend Colin Firth
your good friend Colin Firth he's been
taking the internet by storm have you
seen this no what's he do over the last
24 hours a young Colin Firth has
literally taken the internet by you're
aware you're an internet sensation
that's reflective I'm you reach an age
when your young self is like an alien
I'm a completely different species from
the person you are now I think it's
great I think he's even sexier now for
92
[Music]